my opponent tonight is activist an alter
ego ma Oh Lu Oh
here's what you need to know her new
book is called so you want to talk about
race I can't wait for the sequel
friendship destroying argument
she's the editor-at-large at the
establishment a media platform run and
funded by women I look forward to man's
plating truth to power and Harper's
Bazaar called her book one of the ten
books to read in 2018 stops planning my
life Harper you job Oh a little
everybody so you want to talk about race
I generally do not why are you making me
talk about race well I figured titling
it so you've been dragged kicking and
screaming into talking about race was a
bit long it is long yeah so I figured
I'd give you the benefit of the doubt
since you're there you have to have the
conversation might as well say you
wanted to do it in the first place great
so you put me a position of power how do
I win how do I win the conversation
about race you know what's interesting
is you really can't win a conversation
about race well you got to give me a
shot you know so we're talking about
lived realities right if you say that
you had cereal for breakfast and I say
no you did not have cereal for breakfast
I can't really win that conversation if
I say I had oatmeal so that means you
didn't have cereal there's no winner in
that conversation when we're talking
about race we're talking about what I
experienced as a black woman what you
experienced as a white man there's no
winner when we're talking about lived
experiences there's only understanding
but what if I ate all the eggs so nobody
could have breakfast that's an
experience that we all share I'm the guy
who gets breakfast and you don't is that
well then the conversation really is
about why you ate all of the eggs and
you felt that was appropriate and that
might have something to do with race you
think so it marks
I just have an instinct to want
everything and more and neglect other
people having the equal amount I don't
see the connection we'll look at your
book here your titles of each chapter
they kind of do the interview for me you
break it down each chapter what is
racism why am I always being told to
check my privilege why can't I touch
your hair I just call it I just got
called racist what do I do now
hypothetical I just got called racist
what do I do now I would say first take
a deep breath before you start
responding and say no I'm not racist I
didn't do anything racist stop and
listen and think someone is trying to
give me an opportunity to learn about my
actions and how they may be harming
someone and pause and think where can I
learn ask more questions ask what you
said or did that might have been racist
and maybe Google a little because
chances are you're not the first person
to do that thing and chances are
someone's written a lot about why it is
racist are these conversations happening
in America do people want to have this
conversation these conversations are
definitely happening but when they
happen without such and care it's pretty
much just a shouting match but we need
to be able to talk about race because
believe it or not we're always talking
about race we're talking about it in the
ways in which we don't ask people what
they need and what their experiences are
we're talking about it in our everyday
decisions so we might as well try to do
it with a little thought and care
did you see the Super Bowl last night I
did not I did like you though see a lot
of the commercial there was make
commercials right is it inspiring that
we've gotten to a place where somebody
like MLK can sell us trucks I'm gonna
have to impose a moratorium on white
people ever talking about Martin Luther
King it's it's something I feel like has
been abused
I would first say write a book report on
Martin Luther King and then maybe you
can talk about him because until it's
been shown that it can be done
responsibly by white America I think
it's best to leave that to us for now
isn't he a good gateway hero to start
talking about race oh I would absolutely
love it if people would listen to what
dr. King said okay that's what angle do
you have something else I know my book
is called so you want to talk about race
but it's really so some people need to
listen about race while other people
talk about race and the people who need
to listen or kind of like you tell me
something I already know what you
already know is that race is in
everything
and when you are not talking about race
when you think you're not talking about
race you're talking about whiteness
because it is infused our entire culture
so if you don't want to say play the
race card you'll start talking about
race with more intention so that way we
can actually discover issues of racial
oppression in this society and get to
the point where things maybe won't be
always about race it's in everything
everything
it's like paprika yes good to know
her book is called so you want to talk
about race Iijima Alou Oh everyone